yo yo yo is that the dulcet tone of
ludwig that i hear
dulcet is never a word i've heard
describing me but you are right it is me
very good so thank you charlie to
boot how's it going
big men this call is huge might take
down discord yeah this is a big man call
right here gentlemen
this is finally it happens though just
waiting for this meeting
my entire life i can't believe we could
merge i think we take down the candidate
series and beat magnus
that's what i was just saying on stream
too
yeah he wouldn't stand the chance well
okay that's dog okay hurtful
lorraine don't let him get in your head
man it's too early for this thanks
thanks we have a battle to the death
today
uh us two versus you two no friendships
all rivalries
um and a little bout of hand
foot brain mind
sounds amazing i i'm looking forward to
this
very very much i thought we'd make it a
little spicy charlie i thought we'd
maybe throw a little on this how many
subs
what about a classy 25
that is a little that is a little more
upscale for this restaurant i suppose
yeah
yeah it's you know you stay a while you
know
have a little fun with it all right we
can do 25.
[Music]
well actually we haven't our time hasn't
started so that's good good to know he's
staying hydrated
oh we're in the game already yeah what
the heck okay so we have to we have to
exit to this call to our own call though
or do we just
do we start calling you can hear my
brain if you want
are brains supposed to yeah i guess
that's f oh the game got aborted
i think it's fine i mean it depends on
the how we want to do it but i i'd be
fine with that like
hes what do you think don't put me on
the spot man it seems like you wanted to
be in your own room with me
so like spending some alone time with
hess sure
absolutely like the average man does
but if everyone else doesn't want me to
spend some
time with hess then i won't well
it's it's up to you i'm playing this
again regardless
i will say in the same same call same
call because i think i'll get your heads
all right do we are we doing a
particular color i guess we're just
doing
random color i don't care man
dude i think just random let the gods
decide sounds good
i challenge random yeah i challenge you
i haven't received a challenge so oh yes
i am i'm pretty sure you have
we're right
i feel like ron weasley i'm gonna go
with that e5 this time
uh tonight night
pawn pawn
really going to this line charlie has
some excitement
um you've they're the best brand i've
ever had
hmm the speed wow
that would be oh my eval bar is open
okay i got to close out my bathroom wait
yes that was mine
[Laughter]
at the top right wait did you stamp
yesterday or not yet
yeah of course i did i said uh i said
night oh sorry seriously
deviating from your game against knight
pawn
[Music]
[ __ ] i forget
i forget what it is
pawn
uh has to be knight
bishop
bishop
oh and i think i know i'm very excited i
think i remember it i think i remembered
i certainly don't this is not typically
how i play it
i'm lost right now that was the
intention
yeah now we've got you right where we
want you exactly
um
yeah i think it has to be
let's accept thanks everybody for the
subs appreciate it guys
i think we i think we have to hit the
king move here
all right king
i believe the next order of business is
pawn sounds fantastic to me
um
i did say pawn okay you just said it as
if you maybe were repeating them
or
no i think we have to take back with the
pawn here fixes uh our pawn structure a
little bit no more double pawns
bishop
oh that is an interesting bishop to be
moving um
i think we need to start moving our
bishop now as well
waiting for a lot to say it's a cowardly
move
you would never yeah
pawn
ah i think we go on here on
yes all right happy to accommodate that
sir
okay when you say things like that i get
a nice little smile on my face
it's the right one yeah i'm always on
i'm always encouraging man
i would say in this circumstance
it would be beneficial
to move
a pawn
and now i think it would be beneficial
to to move
[Laughter]
to move you were expecting the move to
announce itself after the end of that
yes
like an anime scene of course i'm
thinking
i'm thinking we we go pawn okay
queen oh goodness
what a disgusting move
[Laughter]
how dare you suggest that i recapture
something
there's a lot of things i like about
this position
i think daniel do i like things about
this position
you like a lot of things about this
position man okay so what i'm looking at
is bishop
yeah i like a lot of things about the
fact that you like a lot of things about
it
um i'm thinking i
still like where where my heart's at
here i'm thinking this is gonna be a
rook from us as well
okay
hmm
tonya i'm i'm thinking that you might be
at the end of your
[ __ ] rope your business is that so
loud is that so you
don't know the first thing about it
that's god
damn right because we're gonna make
a night move oh shoot i miss that oh
god yo well done you missed it because
love is goated
yeah yeah cracked this is a pretty high
level game right here
i do think what i wanted to do still
works
um i could i could be wrong i'm probably
wrong
um wait don't be in your own head
charlie
oh that was still encouraging you're
you're very supportive
it was nice no beating your head [ __ ]
[Laughter]
eat dirt let's go is this good cop bad
cop
i think and and i i could i could be way
off my
rocker here but i think what we want
no i don't think i'm going insane oh god
um
come on charles get
foxy come out there and play
i know what i want don't don't call me
crazy i want a pawn move
you're so crazy you're the craziest
person i've ever seen
or heard of my entire life i think
i think that is yeah
i don't think this works now that i've
said
where you had another mind a night move
oh my i
i knew that's where we were going geez
we're happy we ended there yeah we won't
be able to handle the complications
expected that was expected uh so you
would call them complications then
yes yes i wouldn't use that nomenclature
i think what's happened here is he's
fallen for our
trap right exactly
the white gambit which is i think
a night move crazy enough crazy as it
sounds oh
a night move yes there's many
all right how should we do this
[Laughter]
i think we might go yeah look at that
aggressive
aggressive sally
is that what you're thinking that's not
a bad news though i think is that what
you were
ironically that was exactly like that
actually was what i had mine
trading off the strongest fees you know
yeah
that's not a bad move need i remind you
of the
marvin marvin yeah i've learned a lot
right ludwig's learning about this
because sardoche should have done this
you know according to all the
commentaries when he's playing that
match so
that he's important he might forgotten
though
i would like to do
i kind of want to get a bit [ __ ] nuts
just get wild just get hog wild right
now
dude [ __ ] wild
and then i think our follow-up
that sound means there's a four-minute
think that's about to accompany it
i know that sound very well
i've started doing that on my streams
actually like
it helps with getting the juices flowing
it changes saliva to brain cells it's
like starting the car yeah
i'm starting to i'm starting to overload
here i had some good ideas
get up warm up the engine yeah i gotta
get her revved up again get the juice in
the tank i
think what i want
is rook move
okay yeah yeah we can we can we can we
can accommodate that
you can certainly accommodate that i
think i want to make a
[ __ ] bishop move
and then i would also like to
make a bishop move
i think i want to make
all right hold up i gotta sit in the
tank for a second here please
take all the six minutes here
i think i want to make it
i muted myself dude if blood finds queen
takes
d5 that's crazy lot is playing really
well he's making a lot of really really
good moves here i mean charlie's playing
decently
but i didn't expect knight b5 actually
that was insane
i think
so
i would like to play
a queen move
i think that wasn't that good now yeah
that's crazy i mean but it's not over
i see what you see lud and i also can't
tell if that's just not good
let's go
look i just want to scare you a little
bit dude
you've fallen into a vicious trap yeah
you just don't know it
i'm guessing you don't know it either
but neither do we
no i i i think i know exactly
what i'd like that would be
well you got to give me a second that
means absolutely
i'll give you more than don't don't rush
the guy down yet yeah why
just you're doing his best really trying
hard
let's just let this turn into a bullet
game
that is very far from over very far from
over knight b6 we're still in the game
sure yeah you can listen some music or
something maybe they'll help
you could also turn back time
i'll tell you what i really like boys
it's a um it's a night move
okay
they have improved so much look at the
quality of this game it's it's crazy
like
they're both i mean particularly ludwig
but charlie too like
they this is very high quality
suggestions for the most part
it pulls the music on you know well i
think i just need to make it
god damn
let's make out
[Laughter]
did you say crossing our nuts yeah
yes the nuts are crossed aren't they
i think i'll make a queen move
call me crazy i think i want to make a
pawn move crazy
i won't call you crazy but i might call
you some other things
okay but that's that's quite reasonable
yes because
i would like to make a rook move
problem is a situation where there's a
good move available with every single
piece
so
i think that's what i'm struggling with
jesus [ __ ] christ um
let's let's not get too wacky i guess
let's make a simple
which move did you want to make
[Music]
i heard rook but i'm not sure i also
heard
did you go to like the marianas trench
or something no
no no it's been a little bit
uh i think i want to make
a queen move really riley that was
hilarious though
that was pretty funny all of a sudden
oh
is it better charlie oh absolutely
all right lord should we do it for the
fans
[ __ ] yeah do it for the fans yeah
everything wow oh my god what a
is that sacrifice what the [ __ ] are the
fans doing these days
nutty uh it's a lot type of move i just
want to get in your head
all right uh i'll i'll go a night move
yes yes of course
these are some nutty fans dude
they're pretty off their rockers man
[Laughter]
rick and morty uh let's go with a bishop
move
and then i think
oh what if but what if the wonder boy's
not done
what if and
you know this could be it could be real
dumb but we'll never know unless i say
it
what if we do a rook move
that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard in my life and i've heard a lot of
done things
i'm just kidding let's do a let's do a
bishop move
we're better but we'll charlie find the
right moves here
and then i think it's high time
for this is the first time i've said
this i think it's high time for a queen
move
high time for quint i mean it's never
not high time for queen murph
we shall put it over here high time you
know what i mean
who knows that's way too high level
uh i would like to make
a bishop move uh real quick anyone else
get disconnected or just me
just you oh you probably didn't hit yes
i'm here
oh right okay what'd you say uh lud
bishop yeah where are you where are you
planning to go charlie i i can't make a
move without you
i know you need your guidance my
guidance
uh you are you liking that queen
sacrifice you decided on robert
no i i really regret it i thought i was
doing it for the fans and i just
heard us real bad it's uh
it don't feel great right now you know i
thought i just saw something and i
didn't
either yeah um um
this has been a um i i let you down here
and then we're we're just uh trying to
figure out our way
all right let's uh go here charlie you
remember the dark times
i think those dark times are gone i
think it's high time for a queen move
i might agree with that i would like to
make a
rook move
and then i
oh i think it's about to get a little
stinky in here boys
i think i want a queen move i think i
know what you're thinking
but yeah i did it for the fans
wait is this not oh god oh god it's fine
that's why you're getting
it you're in you're in good hands
charlie
i love that you came up with that though
boom
i would like to make i'll do something
else for the fans
see our fans like good moves yeah yeah
we have right
right charlie yeah they respect high
level play exactly
not whatever garbage ludwig
fashions of the day you know i would
like to make a
pod move
i would like a rook move yes yes yes
no i got lost that was the one i were
thinking of i'm sure
oh i would make a pawn move here hmm
oh we're [ __ ] that way i'd like a
queen move
here what the hell happened to this game
i think i have sacrificed a queen
at some point yeah no that that was on
me i'm gonna take the uh the l for this
one
i'm not tal bro i'm a twelve hundred but
you
always tout tao you're like oh he's
goaded with the sacrifices
at least at least it's ludwig's money
that he was so cavalier with
uh i would like a
uh i think i would like just so many
options i think i'd like a queen move
okay let's play
over here
i would like a rook move
and then how about
how about a rook move from this us
conservatively solid yep oh like a pawn
move
how about
let's let's start let's start activating
this
bishop or something yeah i'd like a
bishop move
so in other words
i would like
oh rook move
yes i would like
i'd like a i'd like a queen move
okay i'm like a queen move here
i can't do it just anymore vacuum
cleaner is on
i'm sorry that's on me all right what
was your vision has you you went out of
pocket you had a vision
yeah no i the vision was just was we
were crushing that one it was honorable
it was honorable
no you guys both are playing awesome and
then
are you supposed to hear the with the
rook there yeah i want to take with the
rook on d7
to like why does that matter because i
just want to get active and then
later the bishop could come to c4 go
after the f7 pawn and
we have two pieces and two pawns for the
queen so i thought it just looked juicy
yeah it's a mess there it's hard for
black to play practice i'm not with that
i'm not with that vision my man but
you're this
you love sacrificing things yeah i like
sacking everything that's not the queen
i actually am a simp for this
i'm a queen sin
yeah maybe queen b1 that position yeah
quimby one was of course a good move but
i went for the
you know the flare and there's no shame
in that
lovely let you down buddy it's all right
gamer we uh we still won
one game and at the end of the day um
i mean we are all losers for having to
deal with donya's puns
finally truth was spoken tonight i was
waiting for that
charlie you know that russian school
chess always comes out on top from the
end
oh yeah we're we're iron clad we'll take
him down
next time yes yes yeah i mean loving
maybe i'm just bad for you man
maybe that's what the verdict is twitch
rivals for each other are you breaking
each other we're gonna make it work
stop stop i'll call you later
i'm just letting you know that you know
maybe it's my fault maybe i'm just
it's not it's new it's us gifting
charlie's channel i don't know what that
may be
uh all right gamers ggs all around from
handshakes
big kisses indeed